at a televised cabinet meeting last week
embattled Veterans Affairs Secretary
David Shulkin switched assigned seats to
sit next to the president calls for his
removal have hit a fevered pitch with
Trump political appointees at the VA
calling for his removal a shift in tone
from the White House last week secretary
Salkin has done a great job an inspector
general report revealed Shulkin accepted
wimbledon tickets and billed the
taxpayer for his wife's travel he's
apologized and paid back the money
necessary now the Inspector General is
investigating whether his security
detail was made to run personal errands
and deliver furniture from Home Depot to
shulk ins home the president is
considering replacing Shulkin with
Department of Energy Secretary Rick
Perry though today Perry told reporters
he's not interested Rick Perry would
really shake the place up and parlor the
VA needs shaken up adding to shulk ins
headaches is a generational divide among
veterans groups those most seriously
injured from the Iraq and Afghan Wars
want the VA to move faster towards
giving vets the choice of seeing private
doctors this is very much of a
generational issue younger veterans
don't understand why we need to drive
2030 miles to get a prescription filled
when we have a perfectly suitable
pharmacy you know two blocks away
traditional veterans groups like the
American Legion have come to Shulkin to
fence and worry the president supporters
want to privatize the VA secretary
Shulkin has done a good job there's been
more legislation passed and programs
that have been created under dr. Shelton
Sud be sad to see him go Secretary
Shulkin is an Obama holdover he received
100 votes during his Senate confirmation
hearing and was once a favorite of the
president now he may be the next out the
door
Brett Jennifer Griffin at the Pentagon
Jennifer thank you